[Music]
hi everyone my name is Anna Miguel and I
work as a lead UI developer at field
intelligence where we take care of
optimizing and simplifying the supply
chain for pharmaceutical products and
we're working mainly in developing
markets namely Nigeria and Kenya at the
moment
I also hold the title of Google
developer experts in the web
Technologies area
the title of my talk is the secret web
performance metric no one is talking
about and to get you all on the same
page with me let's start with the short
definition of what web performance is so
web performance refers to the speed in
which web pages are downloaded and
displayed on the user's browser
so you assumed correctly we're going to
talk about web performance today but I
have a disclaimer to make we're going to
talk about more user experience
connected to the web performance and
also how my perspective changes after
working for the project directed at the
African market so it will be from a
perspective of a of an average African
user
and you might think well why should I
care
um Africa is so far
um I'm not really working on a project
targeted towards Africa I'll probably
never will
um well truth is you never know I live
in Poland also never told our work and
project like that and well I'm currently
Nigeria every now and then
um also it's not really only about users
who are in Africa it's also about users
who tend to have a bit different
circumstances that than most of us while
using the web so this is a problem for
anyone
that is using an old device
that is located in some rural area tries
to access the internet from from some
remote places or even for anyone who is
using on a daily basis some like
Enterprise dashboards like very heavy in
the data how to optimize not really
working really well in general
so when I started working on this new
project I realized that um what I told
about with performance first
well
when you start looking for articles or
like information about webmetrics uh
related to the web performance there's
one thing that you realize that the
targets at a very privileged user the
created with privileged user in mind and
the case is that
well it's normal because I assume most
people who are working on this metrics
are either from Europe from us from
Southeast Asia and they are like used to
a great connection at most of the time
for them what performance issues start
mostly when they for example go to the
Metro or maybe when they visit someone
in some remote place but in general like
for them web performance is like on a
daily basis they're using fast device
they have a stable connection and uh I
would assume that most of the time these
are people who are working on the
metrics and this is not the case for a
lot of users
of the internet unfortunately and even
when uh when you start looking for these
metrics uh the official docs will uh
will mention how
um which speeds uh for example like this
and that metric should be optimized for
let's say 200 milliseconds uh for
average Hardware so we assume like users
with average Hardware all the stats that
will
um they'll most used to convince people
to start optimizing the web performance
a lot of them will will talk about like
how optimizing 100 milliseconds of time
give has given some more like retail
to a certain company like how someone
sold more or something and this is well
this is um
so this is like a web performance
optimization for people who are already
used to Quick websites at most most of
the time and for them any sloppiness
um it's weird but some users
um for them the good web performance is
not achievable at all not
um they are just used to bad web
performance so I want to quote here a
really good article about
um
uh caching of the JS it has a really
great quotes in there so it says at a
high level there are two primary
performance bottlenecks on the web
first networking which is the round trip
time to acquire an asset or data payload
from a remote server and the second is
end user device compute the amount of
computational power overheads required
to the and the uh required on the end
user's device so let's start with the
networking as you can see the networking
definition from this quote is very
similar to the
um to this of latency so the definition
of latency is latency is generally
considered to be the amount of time of
time it takes for from when a request is
made by the user to the time it takes to
the response to get back to the user so
it means like the moment you open a
website on your phone on your laptop the
request is made it needs to go wherever
the data is sold wherever the CDN the
server is and then back to you
so
um you can imagine that the longer this
way the longer the weight and the
problem is that latency in most parts of
Africa is really really high and this is
due to the infrastructure with it which
is unfortunately underdeveloped and will
stay like that for quite a long time
they don't really have uh almost at all
CDN hubs in there so apart from South
Africa and some Northern African
countries so what it means that is that
most of the websites are hosted outside
of Africa for example for Nigeria I
think around 90 percent of websites are
hosted in U.S so imagine going to the
news site and like the request needs to
make it all the way to the US and back
from sub-Saharan Africa
um and the high latency means long time
to First Bite so the ttfp so it means
like this first bits of informational
gets to you uh in a longer time
and to quote Harry robots while good
time to first buyer doesn't necessarily
mean you will have a fast website a bad
time to First Bite almost certainly
guarantees a slogan so as you can see we
are already guaranteed a slow
performance from one of the angles now
let's go to the second angle from the
previous quote which was end user device
compute so this is about devices used
and in Africa well
um obviously you have all types of
devices but it is very heavy on the
usage of mobile devices in there most
users will will be uh with their mobile
devices and it's not like the uh using
the mobile device to view Internet now
and then they come back to the desktop
device for some uses the the handheld
device the mobile is like the only way
they can access Internet also it was for
example the first time the the access
internet was
uh was on the phone so I have a good
quote which
um about the Nigeria so the country is
considered a mobile First Market where
infrastructure and online usage
development skipped wide-ranging desktop
PCA adoption and went straight to the
mobile internet usage by inexpensive
smartphones instead so uh this last part
about inexpensive devices yeah there's a
lot of users who will be having
devices that have a really low
compute Powers there's like for example
a popular device a brand called techno
specific for specifically developed for
this Market which has two qualities one
of them is it is cheap and second one is
that it is keeping the battery level for
a really long time because a lot of
times you're not able to to charge your
phone
uh when the power is out
um and this translates to uh longer past
compile times to quote adios money time
spent in past compile can be often two
to five times as long on phones as on
desktop so if in Nigeria around 75 users
are only on the mobile for them it's
already
quite a worthy experience and there's a
slide which probably will not see what's
really written on it but basically it
shows like the the less powerful device
the longer it takes for it to to pause
the website so what it means now that we
have this data that came to us with
already like delayed because of the
latency our browser also needs to take
time to convert the scripts and all the
assets we sent to the user to show the
website to the user and
um
if the device is less powerful well it
will take more time
so as you can see from both angles
there's a performance bottleneck for
most of the users in Africa obviously
there are users who have like Fast
device those users who's going to have
who are going to have a Wi-Fi
but a lot of people will not and we
cannot forget about them so I would like
to propose the new web performance
metric secret web performance metric
patience
obviously this is a completely made up
metric and a complete quick click buys
for for my talk here this is not a real
metric but let's define it so
performance metric how long are you
willing to wait for the website to load
before you decide it is broken and
um for those of you for those of you who
had internet early
for example in like early 2000s in the
90s
um you might remember this experience
that you were able to wait for things
like downloading the song you can wait a
few minutes or even more or well video
buffering was not really that much of a
thing but in general you were way more
patient with things loading than you are
now
and it's the same like for example with
people living on the outskills when
um the buses uh there's like one bus
going to the city and they know it can
be laid by a few minutes but it's always
there as long as they know that it'll
come they're fine and if you're living
in a fast-paced city if Metro is laid by
a few minutes you're like really scared
so as you can see it's like just
difference in perception
so if everything is slow for you if
everything like if bad performance is in
general bad for everything what can you
do let's talk about some optimizations
so the thing that
um I feel is the most important for the
user that has a slow web in general is
the visibility of the system status so
we need to tell the user what is going
on as soon as possible if we're able to
so
um the design should always keep users
informed about what is going on through
appropriate feedback within a reasonable
amount of time this is one of 10 ux
heuristics by Norman using group
um so I would like to propose these
things make sure to give user
information as fast as possible
you want to tell them what is going on
for example oh we're syncing documents
it might take some time or
um like if if you're for example uh if
your app is a pwa and you need to
download the new content you might also
want to tell them that okay now the
content is being downloaded you also
want to tell them how long it's going to
take if you have the possibility to
assess that in any way
and once any error occurs you also want
to to let them know what is going on and
what they can do about it if they can
refresh if they should contact the
supports if they're offline as soon as
possible
I really like how Google Maps does it I
know it's not really popular in here but
in Google Maps you're able to download
the offline uh the offline maps and I
like how they tell you like
um all the information that this area
can not be fully included how much data
will take when you're downloading it
will tell you the progress after you
download it will also tell you how to
use this offline maps like what what is
the real usage
if something goes wrong they'll tell you
that something is wrong you can try
again you can cancel so I think like uh
they're doing it really well
um
another thing to take into account is a
digital literacy we're all here with
developers we're like very skilled as
using internet in general and well think
about for example someone's Grandma
who's using the mobile phone for the
first time it's a really hard experience
from people like that
and um
uh one thing to do is to use Simple
language
for a lot of people like they don't even
know what the browser is for them like
there's an icon in their phone that
takes them to the Internet so you might
want to make it a bit simpler for them
uh I would also propose discouraging
damaging actions because while the
people
um
that I've seen at least in Nigeria were
really patient and they knew that
downloads and like in general showing
them the website can be really long when
there's like any buttons or anything
that can still like go and click around
and like oh there's a button maybe this
will speed the process so you might help
them not to for example navigate out
from the downloads
also a good idea is to explain
consequences of the actions for example
that pull to refresh is refreshing the
page and the thing might start
downloading again
um I I've seen this happen even for
quite skilled users if we're using my
app like there was like something
sinking and they were like pulling to
refresh all the time because they didn't
understand what it's saying
uh you want to render initial
information as soon as possible
so just make sure that some initial
content is visible without blocking the
rest of the view if that's possible
because if things tend to get longer to
load
um
well for example you might want to give
the user the navigation it's like you
know that your home page is going to
take longer to load
um you probably want to give them
navigation so they can go to like other
Pages without having to download like
all the assets that are needed through
the home page you somewhat uh consider
loading bits of information at different
times without blocking the whole View
if you know that's some parts of the UI
might take longer to download
also you want to avoid request chaining
and the round trips for the data
so as we talked about latency so imagine
it's not only for like first requests
it's like for all the assets that need
to uh need to be downloaded to show the
page that takes longer than in places
where the cdns uh only buy
and you might want to try to optimize it
just not to make it worse so this is
mostly about
considering using the browser hints and
there are three I'm going to talk about
first first of them is preconnect which
can eliminate some costly round trips if
we know that we're going to be using
um uh for example a CDN but we don't
know exact paths to the to the assets
that are going to be used so this is uh
this is not going to block the initial
render of the current page but we're
getting prepared for for some other
um
for some other uh assets and uh this can
be used using the real pre-connect with
cross origin because usually what you're
going to do is to use it with uh with
some of the domains and use
um the second browser hint is prefetch
and this will fetch the resources and
store them in cash and it's again for
the next future navigation
and the browser will decide uh if if it
can do it at the time it's just a hint
to the browser oh if you have some free
time you might consider downloading this
uh item and storing it in cash for the
future navigation both these resource
hints uh also can like
um
um slow down the process so make sure to
like test everything if uh if they're
making some seeds and the third one
um sorry and there's a snippet how to
use the the prefetch
and the third one is preloads which is
for loading the late discovered
resources and the main example that is
usually used is like for example if in
your style sheet there is a font and
only then it's being discovered you
might want to in the browser hey I know
that this font will definitely be needed
for loading this page and I know I don't
reference it earlier so here we go
please start downloading it early and
for the fonts
unfortunately you need to use a cross
origin too
and you can give the hints
this as to tell the browser there's
going to be a font unfortunately it can
actually cause the double downloads
but if otherwise the font would be
discovered really late it can be worth
it
another tip is to Lazy load resources
that are not critical so if you have for
example some items that are like way uh
way down on the page someone needs to
scroll their way below default
you might not want to force the user to
download them because they might never
discover these resources and for that
now uh it's quite a good support for the
um native loading flag so you can sell
it mostly for images loading lazy if you
know that some images are going to be
down on the website for some browsers it
works also on different types of assets
not only images but well images are like
the most popular
famous case for that
um
learn about network resources scenes so
Network resource hints is a
basically connected to the settings in
some of the user's phones it doesn't
work for like all all types of operating
systems but in some of them in the
settings user can select oh I prefer to
the saver mode like to save data and you
can know about this from the network
information API you can access this
information about user Network
uh it's uh it's sitting in the Navigator
and uh this way one user says okay I
would rather be in the data saving mode
you might be considerate about this
request and for example not ship some
images to them uh instead shoot some out
images or nothing at all uh you might
consider preparing uh
um less Advanced version of your website
just to let the user accomplish the task
they're coming in there for uh and these
Progressive enhancements for the users
who are not using the save data flag
also you want to limit third-party
resources so unfortunately the first
part of resources can delay the initial
load of the page and they can be one of
the heaviest things
inside of your page so you want to load
in a synchronously without delaying uh
the most important parts of your website
for that you can use async or defer on
your script text and
they're quite similar async doesn't care
about anything else once uh once it
downloads it will get resolved after the
initial Dom while the
um it will be considerate of the order
of the script tags on the page
uh another thing is to test for back and
forward cash and you might not be aware
of this but uh this is now very well
supported uh in the in the browsers so
back for it cache it takes a snapshot of
the current version of the page and when
user navigates to another location if
they decide to navigate back the
snapshot can be like immediately
immediately prompted to the user it's
like way way faster than like
downloading the resources again so if
user clicks on navigation item by
mistake you can minimize time to
um and navigate back for the website so
browsers do it by default but your
website needs to be
optimized for back forward cache to work
well and to know if it is optimized well
you can go to the Chrome Dev tools into
application Tab and inside of this cache
column on the left there's back forward
cache and there's this blue button which
you can click on any route on your
website which will test back forward
cache if everything is fine back full
cache is is used it will give you like
this green green information if
something is wrong it will tell you what
to optimize it will give you a hints
what's not working why back and forward
cache cannot be used for this uh
uh also you want to avoid creating too
many layers so when the browser is
starting to view the the website to the
user it puts like elements of the
website on separate layers and the
layers can be created for uh many
reasons like fixed elements some
animation 3D transforms and many more
which you might not be aware of so each
layer created by the browser will take
some devices resources and for this less
powerful devices it can even crush the
browser so you want to probably minimize
the amount of the layers that that you
have on your page and to see if you
actually not have too many of them you
can use the layers panel in the Chrome
devtools again and it might not be
easily accessible to you so to see it
you need to click on this three dots in
the right corner there will be like more
tools and from there you can go to to
the layers panel and on the left in the
column you will tell you all the layers
are created
for your website memory estimates how
much memory each of them takes and what
was the reason why they were created so
if you see some that shouldn't be there
you can you can try optimizing them
you also want to minimize website
repaints again for less powerful devices
the repaints can can be heavy and they
happen when the user is interacting with
the with the page
and they can and interactive elements
like hovering or something like that can
force the browser to repainted content
so you also want to minimize that
and to see it again free those many more
tools and this rendering tab in which uh
you want to toggle the paint flashing
and just start interacting with the page
to see what's going on if you don't have
too many of these green areas and you
might want to optimize them if uh if
if it helps
so to sum up let user know what's going
on give them the status updates as soon
as possible lots of information early
avoid request chaining and use resources
to dodge some of the time that user
needs to wait
lazy loads content below default make
sure the user doesn't have to download
any resources they will never see
leveraged Network information API we
consider it of user settings in the
phone limit third-part resources and if
you need them try to load and load them
asynchronously
uh optimize for back forward cache
avoid using too many layers and
repainting the content to make sure that
everything is working smoothly there's a
list of resources I'm going to post my
slides on Twitter so you can check the
links yourself and thank you
[Applause]